you know there's an enormous amount of
slugar that has been going on while we
are afraid of a genocide in the future
and I think it's very important to look
at what is happening in Iraq now the
tragedy of 4 million displaced people
and the tragedy of constant suicide
bombs and the father there's been no
real progress in terms of political
stability and there are very presence as
an occupying force he's actually
exacerbating the situation there are
many military analysts also who feel
that the real threat to America is in
Afghanistan that's why one of my
chapters is really about weakening
Afghanistan and strengthening Iran which
is of course very close to the Shiite
Iraqi government